good dance goodbye five welcome to the
Jetta gasps um so when we were bringing
something of ideas what we wanted to
talk about I was thinking of my brother
my brother's [ __ ] hilarious and very
smart and just an all-around awesome guy
and one time you know he gets he's like
forced breaks cuz he works for a company
where they you know over Christmas they
force you to take like a certain amount
of vacation days and stuff what no I
thought I thought it was jay-z's Roc
sorry okay anyways and my brother was
just like you know I wish there was like
a website or an app that you could go to
where you could type in how much money
you had and where you could go and you
know all these things which seems like a
great idea although it sounds like a
complicated yeah the rhythm that we need
to exist yeah I would need to be like
more specific but it's still pretty
complicated right so I mean we so
awesome but then I was like okay I wish
there was like an app or a website where
you could type in how much money you
have and it would not only list where
you could fly to or stay or go but like
what you could get for that amount of
money do you I mean like we buy
everything so we started laughing really
hard and we decided that we were going
to figure out what your money could get
you on the Internet
yes um yes so we basically made a list
of different among each made our own
list right we'd made our own list of
things that we found on the internet
that you could get for a certain amount
of money so we basically became the
website maybe just does exist website
created the website it's just not online
yet I will be the upload wait so we we
made one category of things that a
normal person yeah well first we came up
with that amount of money
yeah there's we we go from five to a
million right and we put you know what a
realistic person or what ourselves
personally might buy with that money
yeah
and then
and what you could buy if you did enough
digging on the Internet yeah so like
Internet Eve [ __ ] things
so the first will tell you the number
and then will tell you what we might
spend that money on and then we'll tell
you the things that we found and we
haven't seen each other's we have not
seen Chas so we spent like about a
little over now like oh yeah writing
these lists cuz it takes a little while
yeah dig up [ __ ] yeah so um you want to
just keep going let's do it alright so I
wanna know what my [ __ ] money you buy
them yeah so we're sending five dollars
um so I guess I'll go first
yeah what did you say he would buy um
I'll buy a muscle milk and a pack of gum
hmm I said I would buy a couple of
5-hour energies that's about right - I
might be a little too expensive for five
dollars yeah might be like $6 yeah we'll
give we can give well that's if you buy
them at 7-eleven if you bought them at
like a CVS or somewhere our spot you
could buy a box of them that's true okay
in the [ __ ] item yeah you can buy 4
cars are 9 for $5 guys
exploding trick golf ball what you hit
the ball and it just explodes not like
an explosion but like dice they're like
power so when you hit it and then
someone's like oh my god did you hit
that so hard that it blew up
oh my god the picture I saw is really
funny that's videos and that's a steal
for five dollars we don't do that yeah
we were like golfing with you friends
yeah a lot of these I actually like
bookmarks because I might go back and
buy yeah the cheap ones are also yeah
yeah what else that it oh that's the
yeah that's a no for some of them I just
had a couple okay so the only one the
only ones I did more than one where when
they added up to that amount of money
got it okay okay
so for five dollars I found an Oreo
dunking stick for $4.99 it's like
literally shaped like a hook and you
rest the Oreo on top of it so that you
can take your little stick and dunk it
into that getting your fingers wet yeah
um I also found a no regrets temporary
tattoo for five dollars and I found
strawberry seeds that are like pumped
with mad chemicals and they grow into
strawberries as big as like apples like
dairy enormous are they like terrible
for you or imagine yeah
do it anyway they look [ __ ] you want
to have a strawberry yeah it's like the
size of my brains hit somebody like this
[ __ ] Giants awesome
it's pretty cool it's really cool yeah
anyways moving on right ten dollars
universities I said I'd buy like some
lunch like a sandwich and like a drink
and something like that
yeah seems like what I would want to do
with yeah I would want to eat my ten
dollars yeah I would do that for twenty
so for ten I did uh I would buy a
parking spot for two hours in downtown
LA oh it's too real right that's too
real and then um mm-hmm
what you guys I say it on the theme of
parking an inflatable fire hydrant
parking spot reserver so basically you
blow up the fire hydrant and you put it
where you want to park so no one will
actually park there oh that's no that
would never work and I know it's
completely impractical but it's a really
funny like that is very funny like you
keep that in your car or something
oh my god and also bacon flavored
toothpicks oh that sounds good yeah
that's not good I had I found some soap
that's shaped like actual poop oh my god
I saw that too that's awesome um and an
honorable mention to the twelve $12.99
tampon flask so it's a it's like a
little tight on my list too so we
thought we run up single exam stuff huh
yeah it's like a little tube that you
put into like a tampon wrapper so that
it looks like you just have a tampon
like any bouncers don't be like excuse
me miss you need to open that tampon
right there that's good
I also found Snooki endorsed a thing
called a crimp dribbler which looks like
a giant you know it how in like a
hamster cage or a gerbil cage you have
that water yeah thing with the little
metal spout that comes out and they
drink out of it like this it's for a
baby's crib oh how to present serious
like an animal you could also fer for
ten dollars you could buy a key that's
shaped like a gun which we all know goes
very well in airport security you want
to tell that story yeah we got stopped
in Sydney right yeah in Sydney because
Rome Rome had a key shaped like a gun
look you can clearly see that it's a key
yeah so like we're in the security line
right
and everything stops they're like oh we
get to check this bag they check it they
don't even show us then they go to get
the other team say like the next level
of TSA and they're like oh they're
looking at us weird and we're like
Rome's like freaking out cause it's her
bag and she says oh [ __ ] you know what's
in there
it's a gun-shaped key and I'm thinking
it's like a 3d like gun no this keychain
size but lots of flats like the size of
a key but it's just out of it yeah like
a gun handle and then it goes out into
pictures forever again and we got it
back and I was like Rome this isn't even
like a gun it's like a key oh my god
that you stayed a confiscated right yeah
yeah so dude for ten dollars you could
have all the headache at the TSA so well
yeah all right twenty dollars all right
you just twenty dollars I feel like I
would get like a cute shirt like from
forever 21 or okay that's good yeah yeah
I would get a cute shirt from forever 21
also but first I would get to Chipotle
bowls with extra chicken and guac
because I think that's roughly 20 bucks
that's a good one yeah that's good
thanks I would if it was more than 20
bucks I would just get guac on the side
and then just split it between the two
bowls mm-hmm
it's delicious reporter science um for
$20 I also found exercise flashcards
like literally [ __ ] that's on the
Internet
yeah but you have all the joy of pulling
one out and doing it in regard for the
low low price of $20 although for that
much a month I'm sure you could just
have a gym membership or maybe a trainer
or maybe just and um for $35 I found out
that you could get um a drinking
apparatus that's like a you know in the
in the hangover how he's got that baby
in the front carrier it's a fake baby
and you can drink out of it oh okay so
from afar out looks like you're sucking
blood out of your baby no it looks like
you're like just sort of like holding
your baby you're like kissing your baby
but you're just drinking out of its head
like the restaurant yeah that's that's
great and disturbing I love it for all
my alcoholics out there who gives so few
thoughts that they're willing to be
perceived as a man hang on a baby's head
hey man is that a fake baby
yeah I'm just using it for training just
kidding I'm hammered right now like you
wouldn't get a flask you wouldn't bring
a bottle
you just put it in a fake baby like it
and it's not like you don't see that
it's a fake baby right that exactly oh
my god completely unrelated the other
day I saw this kid who's like probably
six years old and the family had like
five kids and the kid was pushing a
stroller like mad fast like running
around yeah and I was like what they let
him bring his [ __ ] fake ass like
little nope it was a baby it was a baby
in the stroller and I looked down I was
like I double tuck and I was I forget
husband I was if there's a baby in there
like that seems you know flate like
faceplant I tweeted one time that
remember my old place there was like
that slight hill and people would jog
around that golf course so whatever I
saw a dad that was at the top of the
hill at the end of my street and let the
baby stroller go and just jogged behind
it like and it just you know was going
down this hill and he was just jogging
behind it like no big deal like God if
weif he knew about that he's so far I
know like he who is like waiting for an
opportunity to just let go and let it
push itself that's like dad to think
about all right so the baby train - oh
that probably beats mine but mine I had
tampon flask and then also I had an aunt
filled watch what it's an ant filled
watch what it's a watch no inside here
there's like whatever they put in like
anthill is that like a lamp fire yeah
there's a baby one and then they're just
ants in it and it's like an ant watch
and they just live in there that makes
me feel so weird
and then when they die they're just dead
ants inside of your watch so yeah that's
pretty is there do you have the ability
to get apart and put a new answer
probably not breaks I caught it yeah
it's like 20 bucks three-year-old is
lying there but that's disgusting what
happens if they get out you know alright
anyways just don't worry to sleep I
guess $50 what do you got um an apple
brand iPhone silicon iPhone case that's
too real I guess a iphone to my sorry
yeah way too real oh it's way too real
because with tax and ever
it's so expensive there's something then
they're like so you're shopping at the
album store prices are flat my face
they're like hey so you're shopping at
Alice or will tack on another three
bucks
yeah um feels like it was that it was
that you're what you had actually buy
normal yeah okay I said I would like go
out to dinner let me go out to dinner
yeah yeah fifty bucks
nice kid um I want to draw a cat for you
calm drawing yes oh my god explain it so
we watched Shark Tank like all the way
through a few months back and there was
this guy like the dirtiest funniest like
I want to judge awesome guy is like what
a super like pasty and like skinny and
like whatever in throws up and he
basically starts singing like I want to
draw a cat for you and basically that's
his business he wants to draw a cat yeah
like people would send them a
description and he'll draw the cat for
them
he'll draw like oh my hat sabili just
right yeah space he literally for you
and middle it dude didn't he say he like
started when he was like like taking
deuces he would bring his notepad in the
bathroom in his pocket I think that's
what they were all dying laughing and
then Mark Cuban actually invested yet
now he's got a giant business like his
website as well they are just good money
I went recently and it's like you can
buy a custom song about cash so yeah
he's got a letter if you don't got a
whole team
this is so [ __ ] ridiculous oh that's
where he just wants to draw a cat so I
would buy that for 50 bucks that's
that's a piece of history oh yeah I
might buy it anyway but yeah um I had um
you can also from shark tank fire on the
same page that hands-free umbrella
that's like a sphere that goes around
your head and [ __ ] you could buy one of
those for $50 you can buy a pokeymon
engagement box so it's actually a
Pokemon ball that you put engagement
monkey ball yeah um or for all my creeps
out there you can buy a reverse peephole
viewer
it's like verse if you go up to like a
hotel door or something or someone's
door that has a peephole and they can
see out but you can't see in you can now
see in with a reversed people like it
reverses the mirror straights me or
that's horrible and that exists hmm
Jesus
for $50 it can be yours you can keep
into everyone's hotel room oh thank god
peace edition she hit so whoever sells
that I mean they must get sued like all
the time I don't know whatever that's
[ __ ] ridiculous all right hundred
dollars I said that I would probably get
some gas and like get the oil change in
my car or like pay my phone bill I was
feeling adventurous yeah so I thought I
would invest in not one but two nerf
nukes there's like it comes with this
apparatus that you launch it with them
is just giant ball and it's literally
360 loaded with nukes and then when you
shoot it it flies out and then lands and
they go everywhere oh my god yeah so
it's I mean it's like this much pleasure
and then like this much cleanup but I
think it's worth it they're like 50
bucks each so junior flips so if I show
up like next Christmas buying that for
myself don't be mad all right I won't be
mad I'm just I'll buy one for you fine
but I'm not gonna be cleaning it up I'm
not gonna help you clean up it's a
one-time thing we're hiring a cleaner
after we use it ones in the region go to
an open field yeah oh yeah shooting in
slo-mo at least make it like that yeah
um I said that I found that you could
get a like a little statue of a garden
gnome that's moaning you for a hundred
dollars worth it was so worth it said no
one um you can get this [ __ ] bomb ass
horderves trade that I saw an Etsy I
have a picture I can show you but they
can't see it but it's like basically a
wooden slab and it's got this little cut
for like the stem of a wineglass so you
you slip in your wine glass and then you
just hold the board and your wine
glasses in the board and then you can
put your cheese and your hors d'oeuvres
on top that makes me want to have a
classy party you know it's literally
just a slab of wood with a cut in it so
you could slip a wine glass in there but
it's [ __ ] genius we should do we
should buy that and then throw really
classy like snobby parties I don't know
that's a hundred dollars I don't want to
buy those I want to just get some pieces
of wood and because I know
and then get splinters every we don't
have to carve anything it's just one cut
so it's just the idea that's really cool
yes yeah alright that's fair enough
um mine's a little different as it's
been there's kind of a theme here mm-hmm
it's a gun it's actually a cannon but
it's like a handheld cannon and you put
$1 bills in it you take you to the strip
club and it shoots them all out it's a
cash cannon it's Justin Bieber have one
of those why does it does he probably he
goes to the strip club oh yeah I mean
but uh I bet TI has one of those yeah I
mean it's it's like it's like the rich
man's like I'm too lazy so I'm just
gonna bring my gun not let you get into
a [ __ ] syrup with a [ __ ] gun but the
doctor that's really funny there's low
level fake ones I can't even decide in
my mind if that's really nice and you're
just so [ __ ] rude or incredibly
distresses yeah it's probably the latter
um you can also buy an acre of land in
the sea of vapors on the moon what yeah
goodbye you go buy real estate in them
on the moon that's $400 under hundred
dollars what yeah well I mean I think
it's very cheap you can never go there
Oh tours you can never anyone else goes
there you have legal grounds take tales
as money and killin [ __ ] that guy how
dare him oh yeah okay so I'm simply kind
of awesome right it's cool I feel I feel
like a lot of people do it you just
Google real estate on the moon you buy
it it's a weird website so who knows if
you're really getting money who are you
paying probably some guy okay so alright
so for $200 this one wait I didn't dude
oh yeah I did start with I also found a
terrifying to to outfit for a baby for
$100 on Etsy oh it's horrifying and it's
like two pieces for you so you can be
like terrified of your child mm-hmm good
$200 that's always good that was two in
jars no no now we're moving on it two
dollars so this one I'm seriously
considered doing it's gonna probably run
me a little more than $200 for this meal
but it's a reservation at
sukhiya Bosch Ichiro which is a Japanese
sushi restaurant in Japan and it's run
by Jiro Ono there's a documentary called
jiro Dreams of Sushi it's a legendary
restaurant this guy I thought people
wait for years for that months not years
but like Obama a they're like it's like
300 dollars a meal and it's like a I
forget like a 18 or something course
meal where they bring out just little
places and it literally lasts like 30
minutes he like gets you in and out of
there because that's how it works
he's like you're not supposed to stay
longer it sit as well as and you [ __ ]
play by his rules - it's like everything
you know substitute knows no way your
mouth it's not even yet it's not
delicious everyone eats the same exact
thing right and like it's so legendary
topical right deal
yeah so if you haven't seen it the
documentary jiro Dreams of Sushi on
Netflix is what made me learn about that
and it's one thing out two to three
hundred dollars for Emilio
that's pretty else yeah I would totally
do it if I ever went to Japan I would
plan that [ __ ] out yeah yeah that's kind
of like a once in a life to exactly but
that wouldn't eat anything you would not
it's all fish I don't need any fish at
all and you wouldn't be able to come
with me because it's like $3.00 a seat
yeah you would just pay and just I mean
I'll just stand in the car then they'd
be insulted and you have to go make the
reservation with someone who speaks
Japanese cuz they won't like therapy
yeah you need to go with the Japanese
you yeah um yeah I'll set that one out
all right I'll let you know how it is
okay good thank you think it's so good
and like cool so that it didn't go um
for $200 I said I would buy some
groceries
which I feel like is a you know every
once in a while he'd [ __ ] pay a lot
of [ __ ] money yeah tannoy is so
annoying is it we that's right around
$200 and I'm like I know the [ __ ] man
oh but it's like you didn't feel like
you you really got that much for that no
never like I'm just gonna eat this and
let you know I found that you can get a
guitar toilet seat cover well that's
actually a guitar so like the back of it
is the guitar right on is like still
gonna or every shitty textbook you had
to buy in college um real I also found
the white t-shirt oops sorry
the white t-shirt that Freddie Prinze
jr. war in I still know what you did
last summer mmm for $200
not even I know what you did last summer
I still know what you did last summer
okay everyone knows the even better
sequel as it usually goes and I also
found out at sea um this really really
derpy painting of an eel you could have
for $200 those of you watching and oh
that's really cool
that was that that's like on the level
of your dog painting yeah you're you
know [ __ ] the [ __ ] painting sucks
$200 it's our Jenna best they're gonna
oh it's gonna get worse - Josh [ __ ]
Lee God talking [ __ ] a hurry all
right our next amount we bumped up to
$1,000 I didn't say Mike [ __ ] 200 oh
sorry we joking yeah we're missing this
up god fine I would buy five of them
because they're $50 each we kept going -
no wait what I don't know my math
whatever I would buy five Salvadori
no ko I know $20 each you would go to a
hundred and I have something I've had
her all right there Salvador Dali real
the real clocks but they're meld they're
like shaped like melted clocks I can
solve adored all these paintings it's
praise fate I would buy five of them and
let them all over the place yeah and
then a giant Rubik's Cube that's
actually a fridge
wait that's only $100 yeah really is
that it's on a full-size fridge just
like an outhouse fridge I got you know
like a mini one I don't know what yeah
but it's still like a big-ass Rubik's
key it's really [ __ ] cool that's
pretty cool there's a lot of cool mini
fridges there's like like fake cardboard
box ones and like fake tool chests I'm
really cool yeah all right on to a
thousand well in between a thousand I
read that you can a jar that was
allegedly full of Brad Pitt Brad Pitt
and Angelina Jolie's breath sold for
$500 the description on eBay was
literally like I believe that some of
these air molecules may have come into
contact with Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie please pay me $500 and someone
bought it kind of a deal I mean it's a
steal a steal air man do we know where
that went can we buy it off that guy
I need it I would love to just breathe
it yeah
no breathing oh oh come on you [ __ ]
frame it you take it out of the jar to
you frame it rain bat air [ __ ]
oh God all right thousand dollars okay
I would buy 200 different tasks on
fiverr.com oh my god do this that's
really what you could spend a thousand
dollars like you did you have any idea
they do so many cool things
mm-hmm don't like paint you they like
revise your papers I know what they'll
do on Fiverr they'll do anything on
Fiverr anything I wrote sexy time that
money is like to always towards rent
anything in the thousand is like rent
like that he's playing is so real I
didn't pay for anything I doing this
that is your like bulk expense like
[ __ ] that's your rent money yeah
thousand dollars all right or I mean why
can't I keep a 200 people on Fiverr to
pay my rent
that's right you could right I mean I
could collect all right what was your
[ __ ] I it's literally a motor scooter
that has a cooler built into it it's
awesome worried but it's a motor scooter
so you sit on the cooler what is your
ride yeah and then you get off and it's
cooler and you pull out you two beers
and you drive you you drink you beers
all your beers yes ups your beers get
back get back on your scooter [ __ ]
Guinea packing spot trip over the drive
- bull rekha yes
[ __ ] black roast Lodge iced coffee
extra extra my god hey extra extra
thanks for uh yes um [ __ ] don't drink
and motor scooter yeah just just don't
motor scooter I found on Craigslist
I found a weekend one Coachella tickets
for $1,000
that's pretty [ __ ] it's accurate
though Zach it's too real but not even
at all cuz it
wouldn't never buy and so I found
something that someone claims to be 500
million year old fossils which I doubt
because they're selling them on
Craigslist
it's probably just PVC piping that I'm
also wondering why you wouldn't just
save yourself a thousand dollars and go
buy a ticket to me Museum um oh this was
a I want my own fossils thank you very
much for $1,000 on Etsy you can buy a
painting called menstrual light sorry
menstrual night it's a painting called
menstrual night um one of them is
pouring blood onto the ground they're
just like three naked women dancing in a
fire one of them look literally pouring
boiling blood under the ground
and the description reads a deeply
symbolic representation for women who
fully embrace and exalt their lunar
phases could be all yours to hang in
your bedroom for a thousan know that
that's what's going like on my wall
above my bed just know in the bathroom
no offense to that artist and I do you
homie but it's not for me offense to
that artist all the offense well that's
a real person it's what it was well done
it's very pretty this is just not for me
you have it yeah I have a picture i
screenshotted won't
most of these poor screen shot it's
right here oh no nice I know this is
called minstrel night yeah you sure you
don't want to look at it I'm sure I mean
I can make it your phone background if
you want please look it she's just like
pouring blood into the ground Oh red oh
yeah there's a lot of flow going on
there you know could be yours for $1,000
Gillian so save up your money kid know
what I mean okay 200 people on Fiverr to
erase my memory that's what my parents
always said save up your money kids
someday you can buy a minstrel painting
like this one they won't they have one
in their house - yes it looks much
bigger though it was like six women they
were all naked one of them was laying in
the river
of the blood if you save you money kid
anyways anyways is right alright so on
the Wow great job on the theme of
responsible investments the next amount
is ten thousand dollars and I would
create a home theater I said that that
was like a car or money towards a car to
drive to my home theater sure you're
invited you can come okay okay you want
to see what I would buy [ __ ] room for
10k - banana holders and let me describe
what can I describe it a banana holder
is it looks like a giant easter egg but
there's holes in it so you like plop
them in the hole and then there's just
like a ball with bananas sticking out of
it but it's like it's a lot of money no
no no dollars no I'm comin you'd buy two
of those have I two of those and that
would equal four hundred dollars so the
two in charge which is never it's I mean
it's my if it was on sale I might
consider it but the other thing is a
wearable copy of your own face what yeah
so you get it like digitally analyzed
and then 3d sort of printed but like
colored it's like really [ __ ] and it's
like one that you could just wear do you
have any pictures of that I'll find it
online no I don't have it on my phone
can we Google to find that tell us mmm
that was a dark like black hole website
but just type in just type in wearable
copy of your face and I think it was
like six hundred dollars I think it's a
cool investment what so that's only a
thousand dollars oh this is were still
in a thousand dollars oh wait [ __ ] no
hold on we're 10k no no so that sorry
that was six thousand the other are two
thousand I messed up a zero it's correct
I mean it's like it's it's three
thousand dollars for a copy of details
unlike the movie level like when they
get like fake faces on the movies like
when they get what do you do with this
face do you wear it on your face you can
wear your face on your own face just
kidding oh wait it still mate so you
just be playing face-off like all did
ever that's like that could be your life
for a face up small price of six
thousand dollars was worse than face off
his face on face off face on face on
face on
hey Soph is better oh my god mm-hmm
that's ridiculous
huh $6,000 alright so for $10,000 I
found out that you could have Mims
perform live for you is it anyone for
$10,000
anybody remember who Mims it and it
means is is that one song this is why
I'm high this is what so I'll just come
to your house and that I mean that
seemed a little steep for someone that
was on the radio a really long time ago
Mims hey it's me I'm so I can only name
one song by Mims can you name zero songs
by man all right Mims you can have a
giant circle table with swinging chairs
around it that I'm sure Facebook
employees hold meetings with it's like a
swing set essentially with them with a
review table in the middle well you got
to get off your [ __ ] swing see that's
like not functional for me and in
between this one in the next one let me
tell you the ones in between ones car
yeah yeah I found some for $18,000 I
found a crystal earlier Guto I think as
I say rapido vacuum which is the vacuum
cleaner that I have the orange one yeah
then I wrote a blog years ago about
literally in the directions for that
vacuum cleaner it says when you know you
can dump out some of the dirt or
whatever but if you ever need to like if
it stops working like it stops sucking
up your [ __ ] you need to get another
vacuum cleaner and clean it out riddle
me how that makes any [ __ ] sense my
vacuum cleaner needs to get cleaned by a
vacuum in order to work properly that
model of vacuum is on sale covered in
crystals for the low low price of 18
[ __ ] thousand dollars and you will
always need another vacuum to clean out
your vacuum so just know before you buy
you're gonna need another vacuum and for
$20,000 is those like
eight people bikes the octopus but
through the tricycles that um true story
I applied for a job on one of them when
I lived in Boston on Craigslist okay to
operate one but they like banned them
from the street because people kept like
not peddling they were like running into
cars good well I mean that imagine is
hard to control but yeah because you're
all you're like literally sitting in a
circle all pedaling while someone's like
trying to steer it and it's not working
and also just to know $25,000 is the
price of the average American wedding
that's insane isn't it why whatever well
Julian like you could either get married
or you could have an octopus bike or you
could have that vacuum cleaner covered
in crystals we can ride the octopus bike
to City Hall and get married
near both decibels or both ah ah sorry
fifty-eight yeah yeah I would buy a I
would create my entire home
weightlifting gym with all Alico plates
which are like $1,000 each and then ever
buy to go with it a homemade not a
homemade a home version of the
deprivation tank okay do you what that
is yeah I do
Joe Rogan does that all the tests but
all deprivation tanks ever sponsored by
Joe Rogan but I would want one of my own
house if I I mean if I had $50,000 to
blow and everything was already paid for
because clearly that's how I approach
this list I'd do that I know I said I
said $50,000 is like most people's
student loans yeah ah too real
yeah to pay student loans oh yeah all
right so [ __ ] what would you buy um
well on Etsy you can buy Oh Jay Simpsons
book that was never released called if I
did it do you remember that whole fiasco
well allegedly it was sold on eBay for a
quarter of a million dollars a while
back that this person is selling it at a
steal of 50k so you can read the lovely
fictional tale of you know him probably
murdering his wife I would go out and
grab that
while you can 50k I mean it's worth it
um I I found a very funny painting that
I'd like to show you for $50,000 and I
also found a photograph on Etsy of four
dudes riding an elephant for $50,000
and you could also for $50,000 have
Soulja Boy perform at your birthday
party does it have to be a birthday
party no it could just be your backyard
what if you're just like hey soldier boy
come over yeah so this is the painting
that I found for $50,000 it's the war it
says the word bold with like a bunch of
a bunch of like shitty American stars
around it is the heart is really famous
or no she just says that it I cut it out
of this picture but it that it
represents her as a person and that this
is this is $50,000 right here it just
says the word bold huh with like some
stars around it yeah that's really cloud
totally invest money in that uh would
you like to take a gander is it to what
it's called
no it's called bold new it um well both
of those things are nothing compared to
mine mm-hmm for $50,000 this is on
Amazon a real thing yeah you can buy a
disposable ear plug plug dispenser that
mounts on your wall full of your plugs
like they have those in like really loud
places right we're in devolution zones
wait deaf phones are not a thing deaf
homes I don't understand why if you're
deaf why would you put in earplugs I
don't know I have a such a ridiculous
dense sentence I think it was more of
like a novelty thing like it was in I
like they don't have them places so the
reason that this was for sale for that
looks yeah like the rubber little year
put yeah yeah I feel like they have
those in like really loud construction
places and no it was like that it looked
like it was in a doctor's office in the
picture yeah well I mean anywhere that
you need earplugs and they dispose of
them every time they use them that makes
sense but why 50 but why just gonna
sleep I feel like you can get a box like
at Home Depot for like no I could make
that contraption for like $100 yeah or
you could just put them in a box and
leave it but
on the wall I mean and maybe you just
like put your hand out that goes and
drops - that's really stupid what if you
have three years
that thing is racist what a great
sentence that's was not a racist joke I
just needed it so racist right Rhonda
100k then don't
yes okay I would buy the new tesla model
s p85d comes out in May so cool that's
pretty cool that's pretty cool oh I said
that you would get to look at down
payment on a house in a lot of places
Tesla house where my entire house
growing up cost $100,000 so I could go
to Rochester and buy a whole house
that's pretty good yeah or many places
you can buy a whole house yeah a lot of
places just not only what is your what's
your 100k [ __ ] um so here is a list of
people that you could have performed for
you for $100,000 all right 2 Chainz psy
could perform Gangnam style for you in
person
Susan Boyle you could buy a lock of
Elvis Presley's hair hmm you could also
have Creed perform where's the
verification on that hair thing it was
already boss when Bob La Loche of Elvis
Presley's hair $415,000 um Creed Creed
will perform for you and I found I found
on Etsy that someone is still trying to
sell a shit-ton of their beanie babies
for a thousand one hundred thousand
dollars each never happened just let it
go I know and I was looking at I was
like you know I have all of these and
they're all in the other room and I'm
just letting peach eat them because they
not what happened yeah y'all thought it
was gonna hit a year wherever I was
gonna get rich off beanie babies but
never out and two pieces of art that I
want to show you from Etsy she destroyed
me I didn't know we're doing multiple
things this is why I need lots of time I
was doing stuff this painting called the
mountain which is literally a red
triangle on a blue bag that is really
close okay so it's actually just a curse
called the mountain and it's $100,000 is
it like ten feet tall no I looked up the
artist his name is Q Wang he's not dead
he's not from like a
magical era of art or whatever he lives
in Vegas and he's in like his fifties or
sixties the fucked-up thing is some
weirdo is just gonna [ __ ] buy it
and this one's even better for a hundred
thousand dollars you could have by
famous artists g-9 hair balls with like
plastic for two plastic hair balls made
with black plastic combs and plastic
than synthetic hair for a hundred
thousand dollars this hair
hashtag art it's literally hair in like
forks there's a girl what are they
life's I are they they're small they're
tiny look at they just like on a
sidewalk
oh that's giving me a headache thinking
about that hundred thousand dollars I
mean why would you live in a house when
you could have those hair balls
oh they see now that guy's gonna make
money on it no no one is gonna buy that
all right you know I buy ya a killer
whale submarine what it's literally a
submarine that looks like you're in a
killer whale oh it's kind of cool it's
$100,000 that's pretty sweet
and it just jumps out of the wall okay
but can you go to Sea World in it and
pretend that you're a whale and hang out
with Shamu yeah but then you get
captured and killed and tortured and
[ __ ] right
no you're already at SeaWorld no one's
gonna capture you and torture you at sea
well you captured into the dark about
anything no if anything they force your
your killer whale submarine to like do
tricks and [ __ ] what if the submarines
like not charged well then could you
just float belly-up and then they just
so dark is over so dark
okay so for 1 million dollars well then
okay yeah yeah $250,000 in between our
100k and our million sorry I just was
looking I had no idea we could do who is
just doing its okay its okay this is
nothing it's the average cost to raise a
child in America 250 quarter million
dollars what's it till they're 18 is
that it mm-hmm so you know it's like
more than that cuz if that's average
it's [ __ ] crazy yeah well some people
pay more and some people feel
there some people force their children
to work and become like [ __ ] actors
and [ __ ] okay the bells kid pay the bed
you're Phil's kid all right what do you
got for a million what would you buy
buy a house in Austin Texas yeah I said
the same a like apartment condo or like
a home small home in Los Angeles or a
nice home in lots of places plus money
to live off of and take care of your
family with I would also buy three dogs
and I would make sure that some [ __ ]
neighbor kid caught my lawn because I
don't want to [ __ ] cut it but not a
gardener just a neighbor just a neighbor
k neighbor kid okay and the most
important investment of this entire game
I would buy one five hundredths of the
remaining Zune mp3 players in existence
oh my god sorry not sorry I wanted to
zoom in is Zune Zune
I just want is in for a million dollars
I found out that you could have Justin
Bieber perform for you or you could buy
one roll of actual gold toilet paper hmm
like it's toilet paper it's made out of
pure gold so you like your ass with gold
and there's like gold flecks like on the
on your ass I would imagine and oh so
how many rows do you get one one roll
one roll it's actual gold okay now I
really know I want to make a million
dollars just kidding just decide [ __ ]
done roll of toilet paper uh what if you
like I would just let peach you know
what if she [ __ ] grab that one and
just shoot it up well then she's just
got a [ __ ] ton gold in her mouth and I
got a sell peach Wow she has the golden
around his gold dog make my money back
before he goes
oh my god oh yeah nice and ridiculous I
I just wish that that like there's a
website that existed that told you you
know all the different things you could
buy with a certain amount of money or
all the places you go maybe sometime
we'll do places you could go for a
certain amount well you know if someone
ever wants to start that website they
already have this to begin
oh yeah we're just we gave you basically
like a beta version of that app our
website right I'm sure it exists all
right let's look for it we just did we'd
like did so much legwork for something
that already exists probably Julian [ __ ]
you know so this is all for nothing
all for nothing but yeah I don't know
if you guys find any stuff like on the
internet and [ __ ] this yeah ridiculous
let us know and also um if you like find
things about our items that were either
like altered or different like aspects
of it we didn't mention hit us up with
that yeah cuz we want to know ya know
hopefully you guys liked our chat about
what money can buy you go podcast plug
this yeah that was fun looking
ridiculous it was nice and ridiculous
like that printing of your actual face
that you can wear on your face
yeah just wear your own face I mean when
you were to give is it right no I fit
anymore
just don't get the copy me cuz then you
always epithet I feel like the the moral
of the story here is that start making
art now and just like outrageously price
it be entitled like all of these
paintings and drawings you guys you
shouldn't be sending
into me probably like three million
dollars of our at least three million
dollars of art you should be putting
them on se you should just say that it
costs this ones that make a million
dollars yeah he's terrifying
oh my god they capture the horror and
there's our new generation things cool
yeah but yeah moral story start painting
[ __ ] starting thank you guys for
watching English we back next week with
another pop cat love you guys bye